je commence par le tabac puisque il
s'agit en termes de morbi mortalité du
principal défi qui continue à se poser à
nous puisqu'il y a encore plus de 70 000
morts par an liés à la consommation de
tabac un nombre considérable de
pathologies liés à ce produit donc cela
reste vraiment notre priorité principale
en terme de si on le prend sous l'angle
la morbi mortalité de comme vous le
savez des une politique désormais
inscrite dans la durée a été déployée au
cours des années des dernières années
c'est un carnet dans des programmes
nationales de lutte contre le tabagisme
de deux exercices ont déjà pu être
conduits un troisième est en cours de
préparation et pourra être annoncé par
le gouvernement au cours des prochaines
semaines et c'est traduit par la
mobilisation concomitante d'un certain
nombre de leviers leviers du prix le
paquet neutre mais aussi tout un
effort porté sur ce qu'on appelle la
dénormalisation du tabac dans notre
société donc pour faire apparaître à la
plus clairement aux yeux de la
population les risques li cette
substance alors peut-être pour juste
citer quelques opérations emblématiques
qui ont pu être reconduites et en
renforcée ce sont les opérations dites
moi sans tabac qui est pilotée par santé
publique France qui l'apporte un message
très clair sur
l'avantage de cesser la con de la
consommation de tabac avantage en termes
de santé avantage en termes de qualité
de vie mais aussi désormais de pouvoir
d'achat puisque c'est une préoccupation
pour bien sûr l'ensemble des citoyens
mais on sait qu'un fumeur
quelqu'un qui consomme un paquet par
exemple de cigarettes par jour c'est
plus de 3000 euros dépensé pour ce
produit donc c'est aussi un gain de
pouvoir d'un gain de pouvoir d'achat de
pouvoir s'arrêter de